blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman all right let's start with
something totally different today i told
the story on the bonus show a couple of
days ago people said david you've got to
tell that story on the podcast make a
youtube clip i want to send it to people
i would never send a clip of the bonus
show to anyone who hasn't paid for it uh
and so i'm going to tell this story and
it is the story
of my girlfriend testing positive for
covid in europe during our recent trip
now you're going to be able wait wait
wait if you're if you're writing a
comment you should stop
you're going to have to first listen to
the story before commenting because
otherwise you're going to look really
silly
listen to the story before you comment
when you look at the comments you'll be
able to tell who commented already okay
as many of you know recently took a
vacation to northwestern spain beautiful
vacation much-needed break
fully vaccinated both of us we did all
the things that you're supposed to do
providing proof of vaccination when we
went to
germany at the end of the trip for a
layover ever we did everything we had
every document we did the health app and
all of these different things warm masks
everything everything everything good
now the u.s requires a coveted test
negative to come back home
no matter where you're coming from great
so you can always find a test abroad and
you've got to make sure that it's in a
language that's accepted by the airlines
and you've got to make sure that it's
the right type of test and in places
like spain where everything's closed
sunday and they had a catholic holiday
the last monday we knew it might be
tough to get a test locally so what did
we do there are now two tests uh one
from abbott and one from elum
which are at home tests which are
authorized for return travel to the u.s
but you've got to have someone watch you
via telehealth you can't just do the
test and then say hey great i'm negative
because it could have been somebody else
who took it or who knows what you might
not have done it correctly so i ordered
two of these tests 50 bucks each the 50
bucks includes the test which you take
with you and you schedule an appointment
to have someone observe you making sure
that you're swabbing or schwabbing
correctly as the term is and then if
you're positive or negative you get a
pdf and it tells you and then you show
that to the airline great
so we're there we're doing everything
outdoors everything's great we have a
couple of friends there overlapping with
us they get their negative tests and
they go home and everything's good and
so we get ready for our appointments and
we connect via telehealth and you swab
and then you put the swab into a liquid
and then you put drops into a receiver
which connects to your phone via
bluetooth and the person watches you and
then they say you did everything right
and a 15 minute countdown starts on your
phone so we've got our phones next to
each other and it's counting down and
it's counting down and it's counting
down
it gets to zero and my phone blings and
it says sir you're negative for covid
fantastic and i look over and my
girlfriend's looking at her phone and it
says ma'am you are positive for covid
and we say okay let's not go crazy we
read these tests have a two percent
false positive rate
they send us uh they sent us an extra
third test just in case
so we re up and we get another
telehealth uh observation and 20 minutes
later she swabs and she puts it in and
then we got we got the countdown again
we're going all right there's probably
not going to be two false positives and
uh nobody you know everybody's nobody's
symptomatic and our friends had negative
tests and the 15 minutes countdown and
boom a big plus sign
she is positive a second time a second
time for
covid 19. now at this point we're just
thinking
two percent odds of a single positive
test
the odds of two con
of a single false positive test the odds
of two consecutive false positives
does she have coveted no how could it be
we didn't go inside we wore our masks
everybody's fine how would i be negative
it does
but
two in a row i don't know and the
company says listen
we've never heard of two consecutive
false positives in a row but maybe get
yourself a pcr now at this point it's 8
p.m
on a sunday i'm sorry on a saturday in
spain the day before a two-day catholic
holiday
where the hell are you going to get a
pcr test i start calling around no no
everything's closed
through a contact
we end up getting the opportunity
to get a pcr test at a hospital 24-hour
hospital our contact says go there
say you suspect you have a false
positive nobody's symptomatic as one of
my lights turn the story is so crazy one
of my lights turned off um show up there
so we go
and i explain the situation and an
emergency room doctor comes out and says
you are breaking the law by being here
while potentially positive you got a
positive test
you need to be in isolation if you don't
go home now we will call the police and
i tried to explain no no no these are
you know less reliable at home tests and
i'm negative everybody we're just trying
to go home before we call the police
this point we're shaking and things are
getting pretty stressful is she positive
are we going to be stuck in spain
potentially for weeks how do i do the
show i've got to come back and talk
about afghanistan people are emailing me
saying david where did you go come back
and talk about afghanistan so we call
our contact who says that should not
have happened that is not the protocol
i'm going to have someone who works at
the hospital meet you and we're going to
get you a pcr today
so we go back
someone helps my girlfriend
they do a full pcr normal test the swab
it must have been two feet long i've
never seen a swab this big it was crazy
um this is now like 10 pm and they say
could be up to 24 hours probably more
like 12. it was not a good night of
sleep i can tell you that because i'm
thinking two positives in a row
this is not looking good
we're going to be stuck here
i'm gonna have to figure out how do i
work from spain for what would it be a
week two weeks three i don't even know
how long it's we're going to be stuck
there this is a disaster where are we
going to stay
we barely sleep
8 30 in the morning
i grab my phone
and i have a message
negativo negative in big capital letters
it was two false positives in a row
uh our suspicions that it didn't really
make sense that there would be just one
i mean listen
if we all get it on a fluke okay it was
spread but everybody's negative except
for her it didn't make sense and
fortunately she was coveted negative we
went onward on our trip to frankfurt
just for a layover because of the
scheduling of the flights
um and the now here's the really and i
hate to even bring this up but the truth
is
they barely even looked at our negative
tests i mean i i don't know you know i
i'm against fake vaccine cards and i'm
against faking negative tests it's a
reality that we could have shown them
almost anything i mean i pulled up my
test results and they didn't look at
what was the test you know the rules are
if it's a home test it must be under
observation
and you've got to verify that it was
under observation that the company
signed off they said show me your name i
said here it is they said show me where
it says negative i said here it is they
said show me the date here it could have
been anything and the truth is
anybody could have i would never do this
anybody could have taken the pdf
taken a screenshot of it
white it out where it said positive on
her test
and typed in negative and there is no i
mean there's no central database of
these tests nobody the woman at
lufthansa who looked at the test she she
has no idea whether it's a jpeg or a pdf
could it be edited or not so as a system
you know on principle because you have
three days to test before your flight
you could test negative then get sick
and still be sick on the plane i mean
that's just the reality people travel
with colds people travel with flu that
could happen
but the ease with which one could just
fake a negative test
didn't fully inspire confidence and i
mean listen i don't know what the answer
is i genui i don't know
but um fortunately
it was actually negative
we didn't get stuck in europe and so i
was here
and i was able to do the show
wednesday thursday friday that's the
story now what lessons did we learn
number one
i don't think it's worth the convenience
of doing the test at our accommodation
i don't think is worth the higher chance
of a false positive
because when they say add two percent
chance of a false positive
and you're you know at home before the
trip that feels very different than
getting two positives in a row and
realizing you may not be able to come
back to the united states so it just
doesn't seem worth it i think in the
future if we do this again
i'll look for an actual local pcr test
the other thing is
maybe there's going to be no more
international travel until you can come
back just with a vaccine because truly i
mean the possibility of just being stuck
um for what potentially would be weeks
was the trip great yeah the trip was
great
would that have been worth it to get
stuck there for potentially weeks i
don't know about that i don't know about
that but i'm glad it didn't happen so if
you commented at the very beginning of
this when i said my girlfriend tested
positive
hopefully you'll delete your comment now
and realize that your comment doesn't
make any sense she tested positive
but was negative and we could say to
quote donald trump ultimately she tested
positively from the standpoint of
negative in other words nocovid that's
the important thing let me know your
thoughts you can find me on twitter at
deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist make sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for if there's a full book you're
thinking about buying you can use
blinkist to get a sample first just
think how much you can enrich yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
all right it is great to be back and to
be ready to hear from the audience um
and hear
what is on your mind we are rapidly
approaching 1 billion views on youtube
which is just incredible we'll be doing
something very special for that but more
on that later let's go
to the phones
they're not really phones anymore we
will go to discord davidpakman.com
discord is the place where uh you can
talk to me
and i'm so eager to hear from folks
let's start today
i don't even know where we want to start
how about
kevin from denver you were on the air
david how are you doing i hope you had a
real good vacation i did thank you
um so i was uh looking at your interview
with uh phil gursky um and uh it's kind
of interesting uh the
bedfellows that have been made um
with uh tweets from people like lauren
bobert or nick fuentes who
all of a sudden agree with a lot of the
sentiments of the taliban yeah
and uh
uh yeah very strange bedfellows there um
but i was actually curious to kind of go
back a little bit further
towards the iran nuclear deal
and i grew up in a house with a lot of
islamophobia
and
uh the the only thing
i can really think of is
so we go into the war on terror we go
into iraq for weapons of mass
destruction
and
now uh
all of this you know uh
we've gotten out of there
um and countries surrounding countries
like afghanistan um now taken back over
by the taliban so i was curious with the
um
iran nuclear deal the only kind of
rhetoric i heard from
the right wing was um
we got into a bad deal um and
especially donald trump so was there any
legitimate criticisms with the iran
nuclear deal um
and basically from the right i mean even
from a left perspective or was it mostly
rooted in this we don't want uh
countries in the middle east um you know
uh having any kind of nuclear
capabilities um so i'm not sure so
you're saying was there any valid
criticism from the right or the left i
mean listen let me tell you here's my
thought on the iran nuclear deal
yeah go ahead i don't think given the
circumstances at the time that barack
obama negotiated it that you were going
to get anything much more strict
and where the right lied was in saying
that iran was regularly violating the
deal iran as far as we know
stuck to the terms of the deal they
allowed inspectors to go in and look now
if you want to make the claim
they had
secret facilities so they were showing
inspectors the official facilities but
not they had all these other that stuff
is sort of unfalsifiable if you want to
present some evidence that that was
going on go ahead and do it but the the
truth is
they were abiding by the deal it's the
u.s that looks terrible when without
anybody having violated a deal we just
bail on it and so the criticisms from
the right evaluating them listen if they
have evidence of something then they
should bring it forward at this point it
seems like they've moved long long moved
on from that uh but uh no i think it was
a reasonably
um
it was a reasonable deal given what was
possible at the time and to the best of
our knowledge iran was abiding by it
until trump bailed on the deal
um
yeah great answer uh just one last real
quick question um what do you think of
um
watching the show a little bit this past
week and seeing uh the guests uh views
on it but um what do you think of uh
biden you know standing behind the
decision to uh uh to uh you know pull
the troops out i am supportive of it we
have like a 15 minute video with my full
opinion coming out on that soon so i
won't like redo that segment but i am
generally supportive and i look forward
to hearing your thoughts on the full
video when it's out
yeah yeah great uh yeah thanks for
having me today all right thanks kevin
from denver there
very important topics prescient i would
even say
let's go next to
alex from des moines iowa alex you're on
the air
hey david thanks for having me um
i have been
shocked as i imagine you are at the
amount of media coverage that has not
included uh george bush's name yes
repeatedly regarding uh afghanistan yes
and i i i'm kind of stunned and i'm
wondering if you see it this way as well
i've been thinking about all the events
that have unfolded and i'm left with
this impression
which is
we
got into this mess
with george bush
accomplished the one clear goal that we
had and then it seems every president
there
left afterward
well to be fair george bush didn't even
accomplishment obviously we had to wait
until obama was president to get that
accomplishment and then from that point
forward no one knew what to do i have a
hard time blaming biden or for even that
matter trump in this case and credit
where it's due i feel like trump
deserves credit for starting this
process even if he's lying now and
turning around and saying well i would
have done it differently which we know
that's not the case his plan was to pull
out on may 1st i basically agree with
you yeah i basically agree with you and
as i outlined in you know a segment on
wednesday about this
this was going to happen this was going
to become chaotic and all
regardless of when this was done
the one criticism you could make is that
there should have been more care one
preparing for the demand for people
fleeing the country and determining what
our responsibility will be as far as
that goes and number two
getting our people out as well there
could have been more time and care spent
on that but the idea that trump would
have done it in some perfect way where
this wouldn't have happened or whatever
the part of the reason we've been there
there's a lot of reasons we've been
there so long one of them is uh uh
just the the inertia of one once you're
doing something it takes a lot to get
you to change what you're doing
contractors were making a ton of money
it was seen as sort of like yeah okay
even if this is hanging by a thread and
we have to be there in order to keep it
that way we sort of prefer that to some
degree um but then there's a whole bunch
of different things that that we can say
about it but i basically agree with you
to the extent that trump planned to do
this he gets
quote credit for it it would have
imploded in the same way biden made a
definitive statement and said we're
getting out uh no question whatsoever
yeah i i just uh i'll reiterate i think
all of the media should be indicted on
charges of not bringing up george bush
on a story that must involve george bush
yeah about that let me say something so
about that i made an analogy to like a
dental problem earlier this week i'll
make another analogy to that
if you go
and you buy a car brand new from a
manufacturer
and the car is an absolute and complete
disaster
you put you shift it into first gear and
it goes backwards and you press the
brakes and the horn goes off and stuff
like that and then you bring it to a
mechanic and the mechanic fixes like two
of the six issues but you've still got
four issues and so now you're mad at
that mechanic and then you bring it to
another mechanic and they fix one issue
you can talk about the things the
mechanics failed to fix but it's the
manufacturer that gave you the
disastrous car and in this situation
that that manufacturer is george bush
and i talked about him in my segment on
wednesday he is not getting the
attention he deserves when it comes to
this disaster
right on thanks all right thank you very
good
um okay let's see we're hearing from
people that's what we're doing we're
hearing from people around the country
around the world even
why don't we try next um maybe steve
from illinois steve you're on the air
hey dude how you doing i'm i'm doing
well steve thank you
um i had a quick uh question a couple um
a couple of weeks ago maybe maybe more
maybe like a month ago
uh john jensecki said
that the byte administration was working
with facebook to help um
censor the people they believed for
telling lies about the vaccine don't you
think that's kind of towing the line
there for government censorship a little
bit kind of authoritarianism
um
no not necessarily i mean listen we we
know that there's about a dozen people
that are the the generators of the
overwhelming majority of the anti-vaxx
content and ultimately what this comes
down to is facebook having and enforcing
terms of service now i know what you're
saying it sounds like what you're saying
is
in practice if the government goes to
facebook and says ban these people
it's kind of the government limiting
their speech that seems to be sort of
the analogy you're making right
well isn't that kind of what they were
doing they were they had their team like
the government team
going to facebook and being like hey
this is who we believe and i'm not
talking about like i'm not saying that
vaccine lies should be spread and pain
you're saying it's basically the
government censoring people on facebook
yeah because we i mean again there's
what if i mean again i know you're not
huge what if like the trump
administration was trying to go to
facebook and saying hey we don't think
this is correct like we should look into
banning these people yeah so i think
there's there's some important there's a
couple really important things first of
all
if the trump administration had done
something like this
it wouldn't have been to prevent
uh empirically invalid claims about
vaccines which lead to death from being
made if it had been the trump
administration that did it and they did
it about something that was all about a
political agenda it wouldn't actually be
the same thing that's the first thing to
understand the second thing is
uh the government pro as far as we know
the government provided information to
facebook about the things that these
individuals were spreading
and it was up to facebook to decide
whether it violates the terms of service
or not now if you want to say when the
government tells you you kind of have to
do it well okay but we don't we don't
actually have proof that that's what
went down so i understand your concern
i've not seen any any evidence
that there has been anything other than
the government providing information to
facebook about the content being put out
and facebook determining is it okay or
not
based on our own terms of service that's
my knowledge about it right now
no yeah i guess i'm just using this
slippery slow theory and then if it's
the other way around like i don't think
it would have been even good for any
kind of administration to kind of go on
that because i mean
yeah but here's the thing when you say
the other way around the problem with
you saying the other way around is it's
not the same
for the government to work with facebook
to limit anti-vax propaganda that's
killing people versus a trump
administration to go to facebook and say
you need to ban anyone who says joe
biden actually won the election like do
we have to be able to distinguish
between those two things
oh i guess i'm just the vaccine is just
the example that's used i'm saying for
future reference if they're doing stuff
that they got that the biden
administration doesn't like that's being
said on moving forward if that happens i
will be right here denouncing it if that
happens
okay no i just wanted to see what your
thoughts were on that yeah no i i
understand but but uh unless that i have
no reason to think that that's going to
happen
all right yep all right my friend thank
you very much appreciate the call we are
hearing from people via discord you can
join at davidpakman.com
discord
let's go um
let's go a little bit
uh international let's go to damien from
switzerland damien you're on the air
hi david can you hear me i can hear you
perfect thank you so first of all um i
really love watching your show i'm very
interested in news politics
and my question for you is as i have
traveled many times to the us and i have
talked to a lot of people also in rural
areas
and what i never understood is like i
saw like the infrastructure is crumbling
and they don't have access to good
health care and the school system is bad
but when i was talking to people like
their main concern was oh the president
has to be against abortion or um or
socialism or cancer culture is like the
biggest issue yeah even though they they
maybe have bad thieves or can't afford
health care and
my question is just like um that's
something i never understood or how can
you change or convince these people that
maybe the socialism that actually is a
social welfare state is actually not too
bad
yeah you know i also used to not
understand how how could it be how could
how do people get to be like this and
then i spent some time in rural northern
indiana
and spending time there actually made me
understand how it happens
because when you were in these rural
places
with first of all everybody around you
is is almost identical to you in terms
of their profile it's basically people
that are they're the same race as you
they're the same religion they're the
same culturally they're all born in
right there in indiana you start with
that
and all you have are shooting ranges
um
rodeos
and churches that's all you have
and so
what you go to church and it's these
mega churches and everybody sits there
and the pastor tells everybody the same
thing and it's about abortion and it's
about this and that and the other thing
and so
i understood well like of course if you
grow up like that
this is this this is the world view
you're going to end up with unless
you're really motivated to look around
at other ways that that people live so i
think understanding that is a really
important first step and even hoping to
try to change some of these folks points
of view
yeah yeah so it definitely is a big
cultural difference oh yeah rural areas
and cities and i think yeah i mean maybe
if if they see for example if biden or
other democrats if they um get bills
done that people have more access to
health care and autism stuff maybe they
see like oh it's actually not too bad
that socialism like what they think that
is bad actually i mean it's not the
other issue is what they think is
socialism is not actually socialism
that's a whole other story
yeah yeah i mean when you compare like
switzerland or venezuela or denmark
that's like completely different
countries absolutely there's a big
difference between social welfare state
and socialism what uh what part of
switzerland are you in
i mean like from the swiss german
speaking park like close to zurich like
the central area oh okay very nice i've
been to zurich one of my favorite cities
in the world oh yeah nice nice yep and
your vacation was also in europe the
last few days
it was i've been i've been mostly in
spain and it was beautiful
oh now spain is also absolutely
beautiful yeah
all right my friend i appreciate the
call thank you yeah absolutely let's
take a very quick break if you're
holding right now to talk to me don't
hang up unless you're furious at how
long it's been but stay on hold because
i'm going to take a few more calls right
after this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
alright let's hear from a few more
people the way we now uh take phone
calls is really through the internet
voice over ip technology
um
davidpakman.com discord is where you can
find it
let's go next to kelsey from colorado
kelsey you're on the air
hi david how are you
i'm doing well kelsey thank you
welcome back to the united states thank
you
um so i have a quick question for you um
i wrote this down it seems the country
is uh pretty progressive on some issues
like poll after poll shows that big
issues like infrastructure
mass mandates health care etc have a lot
of support from both sides
um what's it going to take for the
opposition not to dictate the shooting
down of this uh of the support of these
policies well that this this is one
you've come across here kelsey one of
the great
injustices and corrupt elements of our
political system which is that we
supposedly are electing officials to
represent our views
but in reality our elected officials at
the federal level are well to the right
of the american public if you compare
american support for abortion being
mostly legal
to support in the house and senate for
abortion being mostly legal there's a
disconnect the the senate and house are
much more against abortion than the
people
and it goes to many of the other issues
you're talking about basic access to
health care
uh pick you know whatever issue you want
so there's a number of different reasons
for this one is gerrymandering right so
that you have people
in districts that are drawn in such a
way
that a lot of liberals are sort of
crammed into districts where they win
those districts by a lot
and then you have much more competitive
districts where republicans barely win
and so you've got a whole bunch of
people who have the views you're
pointing out but they are
underrepresented because of
gerrymandering that's like one thing the
other thing also is that in general
corporations and rich people's desires
through the money they contribute are
way more likely to be made law and to be
listened to by our elected officials
than just like the average person and so
you stack all these things on top of
each other
and you end up with the situation we
have which is you look at an issue
66 support among the american public
only 52 support among our elected
officials and it is a problem i don't
know how we fix it
it's just really frustrating looking all
these polls and it's like false hope
almost because it's like oh well not
everything is as it seems that you know
you get to see on the tv or reading me
and media all the time yeah but then
again you have all those other issues
that you mentioned that prevents
anything from moving forward which is
incredibly frustrating so it's a really
weird kind of uh middle ground to be in
absolutely absolutely and uh let's let's
keep uh working on this issue kelsey
it's not going away anytime soon
agreed well thanks for your time david
really appreciate it my pleasure thank
you for your call
pretty close to a perfect phone call i
mean audio worked got right into the
subject matter really not not a lot to
complain about there
let's go next to i hope i'm pronouncing
this correctly is it governed in los
angeles or govind
govind
los angeles please unmute govind govind
uh can you hear me now
just barely
uh can you hear me now that's a little
bit better uh uh yeah so uh yeah i was
wondering what what your thoughts on
like the mainstream media like they're
basically
uh like a lot like do you think they're
lying on afghanistan like basically like
even cnn and msnbc they're breaking on
their earth i mean they're breaking
with biden on afghanistan
uh like so what what lie would what lie
do you think they might be telling uh
uh well
they're like spreading like pro-war like
uh they're being like very pro-war like
uh
jake tapper up from cnn
he uh
he brought on tony blinken and then he
was like why don't we just stay there
for more time
like uh yeah and then like they're also
still trusting the generals who we know
are like
really dumb and like they're they are
also
uh keep spreading propaganda so
what what propaganda did the generals
spread well like they're like oh we need
to stay there for more time because
because
because because if we stay there for
more time the taliban won't come in even
though uh if we unless we stay there
forever like forever the taliban will
like just
come in yeah i mean listen staying there
forever it's like what what the hell are
we doing it makes no sense so so my view
is uh
from the military industrial complex too
and then cnn and msnbc are listening to
these people i i to be perfectly honest
i just got back and i've everything i've
consumed about afghanistan has been me
reading i was reading on my flight back
earlier this week and all of this so i
don't know i don't know nor do i care
that much i mean i want to see what the
media narrative is but i'm guessing
fox is basically saying oh biden biden
blew it uh even though trump had the
plan to do the exact same thing but let
me look into what is being said in media
i've just really been reading my news
about afghanistan uh but i i what you're
saying sounds like you're saying they're
taking a position that you don't like
rather than they're lying i haven't
heard you assert any lies
well
well the gen they've been listening to
the generals who have been lying i think
so
the generals have lied okay all right
well let me look into that i mean listen
it wouldn't be a shock
if corporate media was taking some kind
of position that progressives don't like
that would not be new let's put it that
way
yeah yeah yeah
all right my friend thank you so much
for the call glad we got the audio
sorted out there
um let's go let's go next to brian in
new jersey brian and jersey are on the
air
uh hello david i just wanted to ask you
a question about uh california okay
about uh the recall candidate kevin
pafrap and how he's running as a
democrat and has centrist policy i just
want to know your opinion on that i you
know i was interviewed by uh kevin he's
known as meet kevin uh across the
internet and different
streaming platforms and and different
things and we had a very nice
conversation
um he struck me as relatively informed
although a couple of the questions he
asked me were sort of a little they
transmitted a lack of understanding
about some issues
um but i have no idea about his
candidacy for governor i really don't
and i've been away for a couple weeks so
i don't know what is going on i don't
know if it's a serious candidacy or a
publicity candidacy i just don't know
yeah because he mentioned in one of his
policies like in 60 days he'll remove
people homeless people from the streets
and it's kind of a lot of people have
been bashing on him saying like how are
you going to do that you know like what
is here
how is it going to be done where is he
going to put them
that uh he mentioned something about
like uh using the national guard and
setting some places up
oh boy almost like a concert like an
internment camp or concentration camp
i'm i'm not so sure i have been keep i
haven't been keeping them too much but
i've been interested let's make sure we
don't uh make any claim we can't
definitely back up i don't know anything
about kevin paffraft and internment
camps for homeless but i just don't know
enough about his candidacy to be honest
all right that was all thank you thank
you so much i appreciate that call
let's speak next to eduardo from
brooklyn
you're on the air
hi david
hello welcome back it's nice to have you
back thank you
um there is a question i've always been
meaning to ask you really and it says
you know
the content of your show always kind of
led me to want to ask you this why is it
hard to put critical thinking
into the curriculum of u.s schools
i don't know that it is hard i mean i'm
open to the idea that it's difficult but
i think it's more about
there's not
there's not i think there's a couple
things going on one there's big
political resistance to it in some
states and then number two
i think right now in most schools
particularly k through 12
everything's just kind of sliced up nice
and cleanly in terms of what people
teach it's like okay this is the world
of math and then this is the world of
science and here we're doing language
and here's history
i don't know i mean i think media
literacy would fall under media studies
lots of schools have no media studies so
my guess is that also probably is an
impediment to some degree
no i agree and it
you know i
should preface that question with the
fact that i i studied in the uk and i
graduated my high school diploma was an
international baccalaureate i don't know
if you're familiar with it sure well it
um critical thinking was
a two-tier class that i had to take to
graduate
and uh i
it helped me a lot and uh you know you
refer a lot to marcus aurelius and you
know seneca the younger things that i
had i was
it was my curriculum to read right
yeah i mean i would be shocked if uh
i don't even know like
would it be an exaggeration to say 10
of of
of high school graduates know about
seneca and marcus aurelius i mean i
don't even know i don't want to
understate or overstate but it's not
looking good that's the point
that's fair uh yeah while having on the
phone uh let me just note one thing uh i
thought your interview with uh mike
lindell was fantastic oh thank you uh
i have a very limited sympathy for him
but it's still a little bit of sympathy
because he's dr indoctrinated to like a
horrible point
but yeah he's so out of his mind and you
know some people wrote to me and they
said david sir i was disappointed
because you should have been taking each
thing mike pillow said
and crushing him and
like that
that's not how the guy is so
disconnected from reality it was almost
like a performance piece showing how
disconnected from reality he is if i
start arguing about each thing he loses
his mind it would be funny but i'd get
four minutes out of him instead of a
half hour you know
no you you'd be adding nothing and it's
uh i think it was just more interesting
to see like uh
an interview that you you're controlled
you're you you take him seriously right
or pretend i'm pretending to take him
seriously
exactly yeah right i mean you know sort
of uh he believes that you take him
seriously yes and at the same time uh
you know he he exposes himself instead
of you having to go on the attack that's
the idea with those that's the idea yeah
i appreciate you seeing it for what i
thought it was anyway
yes and uh david thank you very nice to
have you back all right uh eduardo from
brooklyn great to hear from you
what a series of very solid phone calls
today i have to tell you guys it's
really been going quite well let's try
matthew from the uk matthew i flew over
the uk recently a couple days ago
good afternoon david thank you for
having me my pleasure
so i was watching um
i think this afghanistan's
the reason why i came on today is is
because afghanistan is obviously
relevant for both
anglo-american international issues yes
and i was watching the uh house of
commons today which is our uh elected
chamber um and they were discussing
about you know uh the failure of
afghanistan it was a full house for the
first time for quite a while and it got
me thinking um they you know we've
committed to allowing in the government
only at the moment 5 000 refugees a year
but i'm just interested to see what what
more can what you think more can be done
because obviously afghanistan's got a
population of about 38 million and
simply allowing in 20 000 refugees is
not going to provide protection for
millions of people and i believe britain
and america
through this long 20 years still owe a
very strong duty of care to afghanistan
the people of afghanistan yes
i i completely agree with you about that
debt did you have a specific question
yeah i was just saying what do you think
can we can do from now on apart from
taking in refugees do you think that
there's anything we can do to
ensure uh stability and perhaps uh i
mean here's the thing
everything we seem to try
fails miserably you know so so it's like
are we are we almost better off i'm
saying we as the united states should
the u.s just stay the hell out of it
should our help be restricted to
being through humanitarian organizations
only no more military no more
contractors i don't i don't know i mean
i
uh you know we want to do something for
the people
but every we just seem to step in it and
do more harm than good
yeah i completely agree um i feel that
the last 20 years has taught that um
militaristic nation building is often a
very problematic and very difficult with
odds often stacked against you yeah i
just hope that this time with this
refugee crisis which will probably occur
um i hope that we the west can take a
more um less cynical approach to it
because obviously with syria in the last
few years we've seen a you know a major
rise in islamophobia yeah um across the
and i just think that this can be a time
for us to you know
at least try and you know hopefully
do something right sorry if i'm not
sounding like i'm making much sense i'm
just a bit nervous no you're doing great
yeah i mean listen i i agree with you my
desire is the same as yours
i just don't know
you know u.s involvement just scares me
because it's been so disastrous for 20
years
yeah i completely agree and you know i
think the same with britain you know i
think this is a
issue which you know uh as
if i'm to represent britain we should
hold our hands up and say but i think
that the you know like the least we can
do is is let refugees in and it's just a
bit upsetting in the commons today being
some you know the government our
government uh almost debate this issue
as if we don't owe a duty of care to
especially to people who help the
british government and the americans
government so i think that's another
contentious issue there's almost like
sometimes a lack of responsibility for
even their own people yeah and part of
it part of the people saying we have to
stay are people rightly saying well we
broke it we have to stay until it's
fixed but the problem is the longer we
stay the the longer we guarantee it's
not fixed but that doesn't absolve us of
our responsibility to the people and i
think that's the best kind of final
point on it
yeah i completely agree and i've just
got one more question sorry i'm i've
been reading about uh the bbc uh did a
little like kind of review of biden's uh
speech on afghanistan yeah and
i was just wondering whether you think
that some of the things he said in it
are gonna
affect his not necessarily his
popularity bit his reputation
internationally like he said that the
afghan military collapsed with
you know without trump sometime without
trying to fight and i think that many
people abroad especially in afghanistan
are going to find that very insensitive
especially with how many obviously the
media in britain and america are often
down
uh downplays the amount of lives which
were lost through afghani troops yeah i
think uh it will certainly look very bad
in afghanistan i think it will not have
a major impact in the global west
yeah okay yeah that makes sense so yeah
um
it's just interesting because of if from
an outsider perspective this biden's
administration was i was really like i
thought it was going quite well like
smooth and stuff like that and it's just
amazing how even in where
it
is it's amazing
absolutely you're absolutely it's been a
drastic change and we'll see how it uh
plays out in 2022. i appreciate the call
my friend okay thank you
sorry for rushing you david thank you
for having me all right there we go and
we are going to go to a break i'm sorry
i wasn't able to speak to everybody
but we will speak to more people very
soon
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to
patreon.com david pakman show where you
can get access to behind the scenes
videos the daily bonus show the
commercial free daily show as well as
special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right
let's get into audience questions it's
been a couple of weeks since we did
these and there are many that came in
and many are good first one afghanistan
plus 2022 david is 2022 suddenly looking
disastrous for democrats given what
happened with afghanistan and the fact
that joe biden
really needs some kind of legislative
accomplishment
yes so there's
one it's sort of still too early to say
but let's look at the bad and the good
so the bad is
the optics of afghanistan which we've
already discussed aren't good for joe
biden even though
he did the right thing
we had to leave at some point you have
to say no more it was going to be chaos
no matter what if trump had done it it
would have been the same thing there's
no doubt that the republican party has
been and they're going to continue just
slamming slamming slamming biden and
then by extension of that they're going
to be slamming democrats for failed
foreign policy and wasted 20 years of
time in afghanistan 20 years we never
should have spent to begin with but it's
clear
whatever the truth is about afghanistan
they're going to use it against joe
biden for sure
what is going to happen with the
infrastructure bill is it ultimately
going to become a full and total reality
news from earlier this week nancy pelosi
working to push it forward
uh joe biden definitely needs another
big legislate
excuse me legislative win
uh and then also there's still the
question of redistricting and
gerrymandering which is not very
friendly to the democratic party and
it's not going to be helpful to them
in 2022 so there's a real chance that
the combination of
if voters have a long enough memory and
they often don't
for biden to be pinned with the disaster
of afghanistan and for people to care
about that enough to vote for
republicans as a result
combined with joe biden gets no other
big win between now and the election i
see it unlikely and gerrymandering
issues it could be a disaster an
absolute and total disaster for
democrats now
what about on the other side what sort
of looks okay
first of all since april democrats have
had a pretty steady three to four
percent lead in a generic ballot over
republicans which deals with house and
senate
now three to four percent is not
necessarily even that much i mean
generic ballots in general
it's too early and it's too narrow for a
three to four percentage point generic
ballot lead
to tell us very much about what's likely
to happen
in i guess what is
two three fourteen fifteen months when
that election actually takes place
and then the other question mark that
could be good is
a lot of these republican governors that
are governing terribly even though what
we're talking about in 2022 is house and
senate
we're not talking about biden and we're
not talking about governors although
some governors will be up for
re-election
the
vaccine rollout under biden
contrasted to
the disaster of covet hellscape florida
the disaster of covet hellscape texas we
you know mississippi it's ungodly what's
happening down there
that is
looking more and more likely to still be
a factor as we get into 2022
and it could be something that even
though the analysis will be did biden or
governors do better
whichever party is perceived as having
done better democrats or republicans
democrats as seen through biden
republicans as seen through these
governors
it may impact the 2022 midterms as well
it's just too early to know
a lot of this really will come down
to how republicans run in 2022 and we're
going to talk about that a little bit
later do republicans run on
biden's been a disaster with afghanistan
and
authoritarian vaccination and all these
different things that are all lies
communism socialism all lies
or instead do republicans choose to run
on something that seems more positive
even though it could be a disaster sort
of
getting back to normal let's get
bellett's foot let's get back let's
reopen even though everything's
basically open
that may be much more appealing than
harping on
old talking points which their voters
may no longer care about by the time it
comes to vote so the answer is
could 22 be a disaster for democrats
yeah i could
it's too early to know
david should free speech apply to social
media the first amendment only protects
against government censorship but should
it protect free speech in the way that
social media is speech as well
listen there's
basically no i mean the the first
amendment means what the first amendment
means it comes to
uh
encompass
government limiting speech
if you want
a first amendment to also cover what you
write on twitter so twitter can't ban
you
you either have to change what is in the
first amendment to have it include
private companies which would be
extremely
anti-libertarian quite frankly i mean if
that's a big regulation of business or
you have to make social media part of
government you have to nationalize
social media i don't see that happening
that seems like a complete and total
non-starter now there's a couple of
other things that i think are important
to think about
if you do
include
social media companies
as
governed by the first amendment and by
the government more broadly
you are restricting the first amendment
and free speech rights of those
companies what do i mean by that well
think about it if you are twitter
and you
can have terms of service
you can enforce the terms of service as
you see fit as long as you're not
violating any law twitter wouldn't be
able to say well we don't allow anyone
we believe to be black to tweet that
would violate specific
non-discrimination law but if you just
blanket say now you got to let people
say whatever they want you can't enforce
your terms of service
that is a limitation on twitter's first
amendment rights that is a limitation on
twitter's ability to govern itself as a
private business which republicans claim
to want so not only does it not make
sense to apply
first amendment protections when it
comes to social media not only would you
have to change the first amendment or
nationalize social media
you're also restricting the speech of
those companies part of free speech
is you are a company and you can define
how your platform works what your what
happens on your property in your
business on your platform as long as it
doesn't violate any law
forcing people to tolerate speech
that twitter doesn't want on their
platform
is a restriction
on twitter you are coming down on
twitter you are you are regulating
twitter in a way that is not actually
justified by the law so a couple
different things first of all
if the government wanted to regulate
online speech
would they have a responsibility
to provide some kind of alternative
platform of sorts if so isn't that
very problematic
second might we not benefit
from some kind of
publicly governed
infrastructure
for helping people to assess the
accuracy of the things that they read
online and this really goes back to
education a lot of this stuff that we're
dealing with about shouldn't and
anti-vaxx is just ideas it's speech it
should be allowed well no it's actually
dangerous to public health it shouldn't
be allowed putting aside the legality of
whether twitter can say no anti-vac
stuff whether youtube can say no
anti-back stuff putting aside the
legality because it is legal
wouldn't we all be better off
with a much more educated population
such that they never start even falling
for the anti-vac stuff and way fewer
people even think to spread the anti-vac
stuff and that is an area where i think
the government could play a role
um furthering
media literacy
i'm open to the idea of a nonpartisan
commission on media literacy the
question of course is is it always going
to be just influenced by whoever's in
the white house at the time it should be
protected from that and i don't know if
that means it's governed by an equal
number of republicans and democrats then
you just kind of have a partisan fight
over it or could there be some other way
i think it could be done and i think
that that that would be a great thing to
do and then lastly by the way
a lot of the
real cases to be made against some of
these companies
are really monopoly cases
we have antitrust law on the books that
there has been very little appetite in
enforcing for a very very long time
republicans now want it enforced but
only as it
impacts social media they don't care
about it in oil they don't care about it
in energy in other areas they want it
enforced with social media
without commenting on that hypocrisy
if you want to more stringently regulate
social media
we have an apparatus to do it and it's
called antitrust law we've done
interviews with experts on it in the
past there seems to be very little
appetite to actually do that
okay getting back a little bit to the
issue of 2022 david should republicans
run on returning to normal in 2022 so i
mentioned earlier in terms of what 2022
is looking like
one way republicans could run is on
stuff like biden's a communist biden's a
socialist
you know mandatory uh inoculations and
biden failed on afghanistan and all
these different things that's that's one
way to do it
the other way republicans could run is
because it's time to return to normal
right now you and i know
these republicans have been saying
return to normal from day one of the
pandemic they never wanted any break
from the normal they were always the
ones saying just don't just leave
everything open don't close anything go
on and on and on the things that were
required to return to normal
masking
guidelines vaccination they don't want
to do any of them and yet they still
want to return to normal so
the the reality is
if republicans had had their way things
would have remained normal all along and
we would have endless more coronavirus
death right now but that doesn't matter
because what matters is what can you
sell to your voters
2022 comes and republicans run on let's
return to normal
the truth is what they'd really be doing
is they'd be running on returning to
pretending that things are normal
i think they might package it as getting
america back to work reopening america
whatever
they would figure out some way to do it
that would evade or escape
responsibility for the fact that they
want to ease every restriction and
forget about vaccines and forget about
all of it
um but the truth is it is a more
positive message it's a more positive
message in many ways and so
when it was trump running against biden
and things were out of control and trump
mismanaged everything
the sober message from joe biden and
from democrats generally of we've got to
be careful we should be careful here we
should be careful there here's a plan to
reopen schools but we don't just reopen
everything willy-nilly
that sounded more mature it sounded more
adult it sounded more sensible
the difference now is
because this is continuing to drag on in
part thanks to the vaccinated
to the unvaccinated rather who are not
going to go and get themselves
vaccinated
the idea of a more positive approach a
more positive message probably is going
to sound good to a lot of people so now
if republicans come in and they keep it
positive they don't go joe biden the
authoritarian whatever but they go
it's time to reopen america the sun is
coming up on a post-pandemic world let's
get back to work let's get back to
normal
i think there's a really good chance
that it works
now ultimately what it will really
depend on is
how does the pandemic turn out over the
next
nine months 10 months
in states like florida where it's a
complete hellscape right now in states
like texas where things are not going
well but the governor just tested
positive for covid if it continues to be
a total catastrophe and the election
gets close
democrats should be able to just point
out look at where the irresponsible
republican policies have gotten us at
the state level you want this nationally
now no no no that can't be
that may be
something that becomes a reality
depending on how bad things go on the
other hand
if no thanks to these republican
governors cases turn around
we get we prevent whatever this is the
next variant from becoming uh completely
out of control vaccination rate goes up
etc doesn't really matter that it was
not the republican policies that got us
there republicans will be able to run on
it's now time let's do it we'll do it
we'll get things reopened so a lot of
question marks remain
but republicans running in 22 on let's
get back to normal
has the potential
because of the ignorance of so many of
their voters to actually work
we've got a great bonus show for you
today make sure you're signed up at
joinpakman.com
we will speak to you then i'm here next
week no more vacation no more vacation i
am here all week next week
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman